[Música]
no se detiene el flujo migratorio
irregular a eeuu pese a la reciente
tragedia que se ponga la vida de al
menos 53 personas en texas a bordo de un
camión miles continúan arriesgando su
vida en el que es el cruce terrestre más
mortífero del mundo
renunció al ministro de economía de
argentina martín guzmán
el alto funcionario deja el cargo en
medio de discrepancias en el gobierno
entre el presidente alberto fernández y
la vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner
la pandemia de kobe 19 ha dado un
impulso a los retiros espirituales estas
terapias han ido en aumento en los
últimos años en esta emisión les
contamos la historia de una de sus
espacios en brasil
en 324 les traemos las noticias más
destacadas en el continente americano
bienvenidos mi nombre es juan pupiales
el reciente fallecimiento de al menos 53
migrantes que habían cruzado en un
cambio en la frontera entre méxico y
eeuu deja patente la peligrosidad de
este cruce pese a los altos riesgos que
corren las personas en tránsito esos
flujos continúan un negocio que
beneficia a los traficantes marinas
alviña tiene los detalles
un viaje cargado de peligros pero no los
suficientes como para cesar en el
intento agarrados unos a otros para no
ser llevados por las fuertes corrientes
decenas de migrantes cruzan cada día el
río grande frontera natural entre méxico
y eeuu yo estoy que lloró la verdad de
felicidad
bastante llevamos hoy en el día 26 que
llevamos de travesía comprobé hemos
cruzado ya 6 países que hemos sufrido
hemos sufrido porque hemos hemos tenido
momentos
que ya estamos que tiramos la actual ya
no aguantamos se trata de una de las
fronteras más mortíferas del mundo como
lo demostró el reciente fallecimiento de
los 53 migrantes asfixiados dentro de un
camión en san antonio texas la
organización mundial de las migraciones
estima que el 58 por ciento del total de
migrantes fallecidos en 2021 perdieron
la vida en ese cruce ni siquiera el
endurecimiento de los controles
militares en las fronteras en el
tránsito masivo de personas muchas
viajan ayudadas por coyotes o
traficantes a los que pagan hasta diez
mil dólares el hecho que haya una visión
o una política de control y de
endurecimiento en las fronteras lo único
que hace es primero que sea más costoso
el cruce y eso quién termina ganando son
los grupos del crimen detrás de estas
redes de tráfico de personas por un lado
porque pueden cobrar más caro entre más
difícil sea pasar más caro pueden cobrar
la región vive un flujo migratorio
recortes de américa latina y
centroamérica hacia estados unidos el
gobierno mexicano reportó un incremento
del 89 por ciento interanual sólo en el
primer trimestre de 2022
el ministro de economía de argentina
martín guzmán presentó su renuncia lo
hizo a través de una carta y esta
noticia le llega en un complejo contexto
en el que la inflación se estima que
estará por encima del 60% este año
además el país enfrenta dificultades
para mantener los niveles de reservas de
dólares que necesitan una frágil
situación en la que guzmán para algunos
ofrecía cierta estabilidad
con la profunda convicción y la
confianza en mi visión sobre cuál es el
camino que debe seguir la argentina
seguiré trabajando y actuando por una
patria más libre más justa y soberana la
tormenta tropical bonnie abandonó
nicaragua este sábado después de haber
tocado tierra el viernes en este país y
sin dejar víctimas mortales o daños
graves
alva santana tiene el balance
en plena temporada de huracanes en el
atlántico la tormenta bonnie tocó suelo
nicaragüense activando las alertas por
posibles desprendimientos de tierra e
inundaciones y la responsabilidad de la
población y evitó familia y por la
televisión que inmediatamente incluso en
bluefields
aceptaron el refugio
y
eso es lo que significa pues el riesgo
del peligro los daños que puede provocar
un huracán que pueden contar vídeos en
localidades como bluefields pegada a la
costa caribeña cientos de personas
tuvieron que ser evacuadas a albergues
habilitados debido a las intensas
lluvias y a vientos de hasta 85
kilómetros por hora tenemos
aproximadamente unas 250 familias
personas que tendrían que evacuar se de
manera preventiva considerando de que
son lugares con solamente con lluvias
normales de invierno son críticos y son
vulnerables a inundaciones algunas
familias sólo pudieron llevar consigo
sus pertenencias más importantes
por lo menos
salvaría mi pellejo el resto que sé que
lo material se puede recuperar pero la
vida
más peligroso durante el fin de semana
se espera que la tormenta siga por el
océano pacifico y también por las costas
de guatemala el salvador y el sur de
méxico donde según los expertos el
fenómeno podría tomar mayor fuerza
el congreso estatal de nueva york aprobó
medidas para prohibir el porte de armas
en diversos lugares públicos la
gobernadora del estado aseguró que la
iniciativa buscaba proteger a los
ciudadanos luego de que la corte suprema
de eeuu revocar a una ley neoyorquina
que prohibía el porte de armas fuera del
hogar los legisladores también aprobaron
una enmienda para neutralizar la
polémica anulación de la sentencia roe
versus byte que garantizaba el derecho
al aborto en el país
natalia plazas tiene los detalles
el congreso de nueva york- planta cara a
la corte suprema de eeuu los
legisladores del estado aprobaron una
legislación para limitar ampliamente el
porte de armas en lugares públicos lo
hace una semana después de que el alto
tribunal anulara la ley de nueva york
que imponía restricciones al porte de
armas fuera del hogar pues me niego como
dije desde el primer día a renunciar a
mi derecho como gobernadora de proteger
a los neoyorquinos de la violencia
armada o cualquier otra forma de daño la
medida convertiría en un delito grave
portar armas en diversos espacios
públicos como las escuelas los
tribunales los edificios gubernamentales
o el transporte público entre otros la
normativa hará obligatorio un curso de
seguridad y capacitación de tiro para
quienes opten a tener un permiso de
armas de fuego él fue destinar seis
siempre mejor que la corte suprema de
eeuu transmita esta decisión a nueva
york en este momento en que las armas
ilegales han estado inundando las calles
y la violencia armada está en su punto
más alto es absolutamente despreciable
y el congreso neoyorquino también aprobó
una enmienda que abriría camino a que el
derecho al aborto quede consagrado en la
constitución estatal una medida que
también está claramente en contra de la
decisión de la corte suprema de anular
la histórica sentencia de 1973 roe
versus wait que garantizaba el acceso al
aborto como un derecho constitucional en
todo eeuu
[Música]
seguimos en eeuu en ohio un hombre
afroamericano murió después de haber
recibido una docena de disparos el
sujeto había sido detenido mientras
conducía se llamaba ayala walker y de
acuerdo con el abogado de su familia la
víctima presenta entre 60 y 80 heridas
de bala de acuerdo con los primeros
indicios de la investigación los hechos
ocurrieron el lunes pero hasta este
sábado la familia entregó detalles
acerca del vídeo grabado por las cámaras
de la policía y hoy también hubo marchas
en rechazo a este suceso las autoridades
afirman que el sujeto huyó en medio del
operativo y abrió fuego contra los
oficiales el vídeo se hace público este
domingo
y cerramos este noticiero con un tema
que quizás ustedes han experimentado
personalmente en los últimos años
especialmente desde el inicio de la
pandemia la demanda por los retiros
espirituales han aumentado con personas
sintiendo la necesidad de momentos de
introspección y conexión con la
naturaleza por eso nos vamos a brasil en
donde la gente se reúne en su búsqueda
de más paz interior gabriel coll quien
nos cuenta más
es momento para la clase de lluvia en el
templo de hacen tela divina michel
ximénez es la propietaria del lugar y
organiza retiros espirituales a alto
paraíso en el estado de goiás en brasil
el centro también propone sesiones de
meditación o rituales de curación con
baños de arcilla medicinal michelle pasó
de hacer retiros cada dos meses a
hacerlos mucho más seguidos después de
la pandemia espeso este sector son matt
kemp la gente se transforma busca
desarrolló la conexión con el divino
sabemos que la humanidad ha pasado por
momentos muy difíciles y aún los está
pasando por lo que la gente se vuelve
hacia adentro buscando la verdadera
felicidad la verdadera felicidad
a unos kilómetros otro centro ofrece
sesiones ayurvédicas y de yoga carol la
instructora de meditación también ha
visto un cambio en la gente por los
confinamientos
precisando la gente se quedó en casa
muchos pensaron que estaban más ansiosos
pero estaban igual de ansiosos que de
costumbre pero tuvieron más tiempo para
ver su ansiedad así que se pusieron en
contacto pusieron un lente sobre quiénes
son realmente carla vino con su pareja
para participar en un retiro en la
reserva natural de la chapada se habla
de un tiempo que hace tiempo que buscó
el autoconocimiento salir de esta rutina
automática en la que vivimos y hacer una
pausa para pensar en lo que realmente
queremos para hacer las actividades con
consciencia de fases de actividades con
conciencia una voluntad de
autoconocimiento pero también una
búsqueda de conexión divina que se ha
popularizado en los últimos años
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
en france 24 quédense porque la
información continua aquí en nuestra
pantalla también en france 24 punto com
[Música]